take a look at the pitch arsenal for
taylor
his numbers on the season six and five
record the era is a little bit high
because of that one start against the
white sox other than that it would be
below four
two two
and he takes a beauty right on the
corner that strike three called
and a good beginning to the ball game
for taylor hearn
a one out single and then a pair of wild
pitches
has put a one-out runner at third base
now here to start the night
jack sends a ball out to left left
center field that is tavares is there to
make the catch
easy tag and score for gosselin
and the halos are on the board on the
road first tonight
and this group will take swings off of
25 year old rookie right hander jansen
junk
and here's the pitch
swing and a miss got him on a high fast
ball so it's a shutdown inning for
jansen junk and after one it's one to
nothing angels
for the second straight inning
it is open strikeout single against
taylor hearn
and lagara sends the ball into left
center field that one's going to bound
up against the base of the wall
ward being waved around
throw to the plate not even close and
it's two-nothing angels
20th double
the season for juan lagarz 36 rbis
taylor we're coming all the way around
from first so here's shohei now second
and third with two gone
down to third got him
legaures
caught sleeping down at third base and
jose trevino
picks up a critical out so shohei will
lead things off in the third in a two
nothing angels lead
[Applause]
sharply hit one hopper
back to back two out singles
leota tavares the switch-hitting
centerfielder also a strikeout victim in
his first try tonight
this one off the glove of fletcher as he
dives out towards center it gets a
banyas to the plate
now the rangers break through they are
on the board
and it's a two to one ball game
and the tying run is 90 feet away for
brock holt
runner goes from first that one's a
ground ball up the middle base hit the
ball game is tied to verus into third
and holt drives one right back up the
box to make it a 2-2 ball game
willie calhoun leads things off in the
last of the fifth inning for texas
great play by walsh off of first base
wow
jared walsh how far he's got to go that
baseball is actually buying when he gets
it and a good feed
sitting down see how hard that baseball
was hit
and a good like
yeah
and then it makes a snow angel at the
end of the play
ohtani leads things off in the angels
half of the sixth
rocket on one hop to first for low
[Music]
earned late covering though yeah he had
to eat it and once that's going to be
base hit and once lowe's saw that
he's like there's no way i'm beating
chauhay to first beast
and there goes ohtani throw down to
second base not even close and it skips
on through into center field
[Applause]
medium outfield gives the angels a lead
back here and a chance to score 100th
run if he could score here
so there's an rbi base hit for mayfield
ohtani does score that big run and the
angels go back out on top three to two
number 25 scores is 100th run of the
season now so three singles in this
inning
it's off the end of the back
smothered by connor falefa but it
scorched through him
mayfield's going to come around to score
and the angels go on top four to two
it looked like conor feleppa was there
to at least prevent the run from scoring
it sounded like he broke his back
[Music]
oh man that just got past him somehow
and that's going to end up probably
being an rbi single
full ford award
and that loads the bases
juan lagar is with the bases loaded
flares the ball out to right field
and rbi single for johnny baseball
[Applause]
five two angels
and red heapho bounces into second base
doesn't get out there quickly enough for
the rangers to turn a double play a run
scores
and it's a six to two ball game two men
on to start the bottom of the six
rangers trailing by four
and there's a strike three on a swing
and a miss
swinging to miss by holt he goes down on
three pitches here two away
the 3-2
he got him on a call strike three
jihadist stayed stubborn with the
fastball three straight strikeouts keeps
it a four run game
fulton
full count on walsh in his pitch on the
way
back door breaking ball called strike
three got the corner boy just came right
around and just touched that outside
corner
runners at the corners a four run lead
for the angels looking to add on here
full count now ochani running on the
pitch he gets into second base there was
a fielder covering
so the official scorer could very easily
credit shohei with a stolen base and in
our opinion of course should
and it is a stolen base for shohei
ohtani his second of the game number 26
on the season
the next 3-2
and marsh tends to drive out to left
calhoun is under it to make the catch
tagging up is wren heapo he'll come on
in to score
[Applause]
it's a seven to two angels lead well not
a safe situation with the angels on top
by five but an opportunity to get rysel
iglesias involved in the final road trip
of the year
2-2 pitch got him and that's how it ends
tonight
a 7-2 win for the angels they even up
the three-game series
a couple of base hits for shohei otani
another record-setting night
as he becomes the first ever american
league player with 45 or more homers 100
or more runs scored in 25 or more stolen
bases
you